okay
um so let's uh remind ourselves where we
left off last time so last time we
started with uh looking at the GPS
signal model which is uh given by this
equation uh pretty straightforward so
it's like a signal that is modulated uh
with the in phase and a quadrature
component there's a carrier frequency F
Sub C so you have cosine 2 pi fct for uh
the carrier of the in phase and then the
quadrature is sine 2 pi fct and then
there is uh two signals basically being
simultaneously modulated on top of the
carrier there's an X which is a ranging
code and there is a d which is a
navigation signal and we said that the
range encodes are typically modulated
very fast so from a megabit per second
to tens of megabits per second
and the navigation signals are modulated
very slowly so uh tens of bits per
second like 50 bits per second 100 bits
per second uh they're they're slow and
just by uh uh the virtue of the the this
major difference between the the
modulation speeds the the receiver can
basically distinguish like what's X and
what is what is D and uh we talked about
some uh pretty boring but important
stuff which was like different different
ranging codes and uh uh um some of them
uh where the Legacy signals which are
still being transmitted and then the
modern signals so this uh course
acquisition and the pyr the civilian and
and Military uh Legacy uh ranging codes
and then we have the ml1c l2c and L5
which are the modern versions basically
and then we talked a bit about the
navigation signals
um so again there's a the Legacy which
is lnav and then there is a military and
civilian modern navigation signals and
nav and cnaf and these navigation
signals what's important about them is
that these are basically their human
understandable uh uh information in it
so it's kind of like uh data packets
with messages that are things like day
time the satellite status is in there
and then uh two very important parts of
each navigation signal
packet is what is called the ephemeris
which as we'll see today tells the
receiver about the satellite position in
orbit because the receiver needs to know
that and then there's uh what is called
the omnac which is which gives basically
the status and some low resolution
orbital information about the rest of
the satellites in the in the
constellation okay any questions on this
before we continue
okay so today the topic is uh basically
there's there's two things
um which are hopefully not not boring I
think these are exciting stuff and very
important and one is uh we're gonna talk
about uh the the the satellite orbits
and specifically how this uh ephemeris
information is used to find the
satellite uh location in orbit and then
we will talk about these ranging codes
and the the mathematics behind them and
how they actually uh are used to find
time of flight uh um information and
then ranges okay so uh let's uh get
started with uh the satellite orbit
um so what's important generally when it
comes to sensing and then specifically
for the GPS is that whenever there is
um a sensor that's operating and there's
some sensing information coming in uh we
should specify what coordinate system
was used for the measurements or what
reference frame was used and it says
this is very important especially in
robotics because you have multiple
sensors on on a on a robot and each
sensor has its local reference frame and
sometimes you need to like translate
information between different reference
frames of different sensors for the GPS
it's a slightly more complicated because
it's a distributed system so you have
your receivers on the earth
which is rotating right and then you
have these satellites in orbit that are
not bound to the Earth coordinates
directly okay so that's why we need to
be very careful about the coordinate
systems and the reference frames so
specifically there are three uh
coordinate systems associated with what
the GPS that will talk about the first
one is the earth-centered earth fixed
coordinate system or the geocentric
system as it's called and it's a it's a
Cartesian coordinate system so you get x
y z and the way it works is that it's
centered at the center of mass mass of
the Earth and then the x-axis points to
the prime meridian or or the the zero
degree longitude your y-axis points to
90 degree East and the z-axis points to
the geographical North Pole and this
coordinate system the reason is called
Earth fix is that it rotates with Earth
that's very important so if you are on
the surface of the Earth and you're not
moving your geocentric coordinates will
not change over time because your
coordinate system is kind of rotating
with Earth so it's not an inertial
coordinate system uh so so this is the
coordinate system that the GPS uses when
it's doing localization it basically
solves the equations in this coordinate
system and finds an XYZ location for for
the receiver now for historical purposes
when it comes to mapping on the earth uh
people because the Earth is is not a
flat surface uh it's it's actually an
ellipsoid people used a different
coordinate system which is a polar
system and that's the latitude longitude
and height system so for instance if you
look at any map let's look at a quick
one together so this grid that you see
on the map this is not a Cartesian this
this is your you have basically your
latitude and longitude angles with
respect to a coordinate system that is
called geodetic so for this reason
um any GPS after it solves the equations
and finds the XYZ position it needs to
translate it to this system and find the
latitude longitude and the height so it
becomes basically compatible with the
maps that exist so for instance if you
want to if you go to Google Maps and you
want to like find a a very something is
it doesn't take XYZ from you it asks for
latitude and longitude right so that's
how Maps work and then every receiver
needs to basically after finding the
Cartesian coordinates translated to this
polar coordinates so the geodetic system
again uh so for for any position
with the geocentric it's an XYZ it's
it's a Cartesian system and then in the
geodetic coordinates you get a Lambda
that is your longitude a Phi that is the
latitude so these are two angles right
and then there is an H which is the high
right from the surface of the Earth okay
now
very very important about the geodetic
system is the fact that the Earth is not
a perfect sphere right so when you want
to work with these uh coordinates you
need to have a model of the geometry of
the earth which is an ellipsoid as we
know there's different models that have
been developed which very accurately
basically describe the the shape of the
earth specifically the one that most GPS
systems use is called the world genetic
system 1984 or wgs 1984 there's a lot of
information in this if you look it up
there's there's like a ton of stuff
about like the geometry of the earth it
even describes the gravitational field
around the earth and so on and so forth
but what's important for GPS systems is
basically just the shape of this
ellipsoid which is described by a major
and a minor axis so A and B the exact
values are given here and then from
there you can also calculate and extend
eccentricity which is like how how how
much it deviates from a perfect sphere
basically that's that's what the the E
is okay so let's look at
graphically like how how these two
coordinate systems or reference frames
are related so here
uh there's a picture of the ellipsoid
which is the Earth and then uh relative
to this let's first look at our
geocentric system which is these blue
axes so there's an X there's a y and
there's a z and as I said the X points
towards your prime meridian or zero
degree longitude your y-axis points to
90 degree East uh longitude and the Z
axis points to the geographical North
and again remember that this one rotates
with Earth it's a it's a earth fixed
system now if you have some point let's
zoom in into this point you have some
position PR that is not exactly on the
surface of of this ellipsoid okay
so this one and the geocentric
coordinates it has an x y z and the way
it uh basically you can find the
geodetic or the polar coordinates of it
the height is basically just the
distance from this point to the surface
of of the ellipsoid right now if you
extrapolate this line that is
perpendicular to the surface so that
becomes this orange line and then we're
just going to continue it at some point
it's going to intersect your basically
equatorial plane right and it's very
important you see this line does not go
through the center of a center of mass
of the Earth this is not an error in the
in the graphics this is because it is an
ellipsoid right if it was a perfect
sphere the line would go through the
center now you continue this line and
the angle it makes with the equatorial
plane that is your latitude so that's
the Phi and then the Lambda is if you
basically project down this point to the
uh to your X Y plane then the angle it
makes here that is your Lambda or
longitude okay so this is graphically
how the two coordinate systems are
related again remember that you get out
of we'll see out of solving your GPS
equations you get Cartesian coordinates
in geocentric reference frame and then
you need to translate them or convert
them to the geodetic so to get the
latitude longitude and height and then
you can use any map of the Earth and
find where you are on the map that's
that's how it works so there's equations
for going uh basically back and forth
between the two reference frames or the
two coordinate systems here are the
equations to go from the geodetic to
geocentric which is not what the
receiver does right so the receiver
needs to go the other way around it
finds things in geocentric coordinates
and it needs to go to geodetic but I've
included these just just so you know
pretty straightforward so this is like
just plug-in numbers basically so say
you have your your longitude Lambda your
latitude Phi and your height H and then
there is this radius of curvature that
you can calculate that's the radius of
curvature at the point you are on earth
that's n and you just plug in everything
into these three equations and you get
your x y z which is the coordinates in
the geocentric coordinate system pretty
straightforward and this is pure
geometry I mean that a picture you saw
in the in the slide before you can
basically if you do some geometry
carefully you can derive this not that
you have to but there's really no magic
here it's just pure geometry
now as I said what the receiver needs to
do is the other way around so it needs
to go from the geocentric to the
geodetic coordinate system and and these
are the equations for it so you have
your XYZ and you want to translate them
to Lambda Phi and H
Lambda the longitude is easy it's just
the arctan of basically y over X we're
doing the arctan 2 just to take care of
the fact that Lambda can be anywhere
from 0 to 360. so you have to take
account for the sine of X and Y to to be
able to tell in which quadrant you fall
basically on the plane now Phi and H
it's a slightly more complicated because
if you look at these two equations the
Phi depends on the H in this very
non-linear manner so it has arc10 and
inside the argument there's H and also H
in a very non-linear way depends on your
file so you're basically your longitude
and height are or latitude and height
are very non-linearly coupled so it's
not like you can just plug in numbers
and go from geocentric to geodetic to do
the conversion you need to solve this
non-linear system of equations uh not a
big deal really you can use any any type
of you know iterative solver like
Newton's method or something like that
to iteratively solve for it and that's
actually what the receiver does to go
from your XYZ to Lambda Phi and H
Okay so
that's about the the first two
coordinates is and there's one more that
I'll tell you about in a minute but now
this was about the receiver side of
things let's talk about the the
satellite that's uh that's in orbit um
so uh as we know the receiver needs to
calculate the accurate uh position of
the satellite and as the satellite is
orbiting the Earth there is a number of
forces that affect its uh basically
trajectory the main one is gravity right
it's the gravitational force of the
earth is the main one that affects how
this satellites uh move
now there are a number of secondary
forces which perturb these uh uh
basically the main force uh that is the
uh the the the gravity of the earth and
and the secondary effects uh they vary
with time so these are not like constant
forces they over time they can they can
change
um some of these are for instance the
gravitation of Moon and Sun can affect
your satellite uh things like solar
radiations uh can affect it uh an effect
called outgassing which is this
unintentional slow release of gases from
the satellite can affect its uh
trajectory tidal variations on the earth
can affect the the forces on the
satellites and affect their trajectories
and finally some intentional orbital
Maneuvers that the satellite can do to
to course correct basically will of
course affect its trajectory so all of
these need to be factored in when it
comes to finding the position of the
satellite in orbit now as as I said the
satellite tells you where it is so as
part of these navigation messages it's
there's this ephemeris part which tells
you where the satellite is but the
satellite uses a different uh reference
frame to to basically tell you because
again it's not bound to the Earth it's
it's moving in space it does not make
sense for the satellite to use a
geocentric for instance coordinate
system that rotates with the Earth so
the satellite uses a coordinate system
called earth-centered inertial or ECI
which is exactly like the ecef except it
does not rotate with Earth so it's a
Cartesian coordinate system it's
centered at the center of mass of the
Earth but the XYZ coordinates always
point to fixed Direction with with
respect to uh stars and and other
constellations so it's it's an inertial
coordinate system and then the satellite
when it when you decode that or read
that ephemeris data the the position of
the satellite it's in the ECI coordinate
system and then the receiver translates
that to the geocentric so it's
consistent with basically what it needs
to do okay any questions
so again three three coordinate systems
we talked about right the geocentric is
the one that the GPS uses to solve for
the position as we'll see there is the
geodetic which is for historical reasons
it's this latitude longitude system that
Maps you so the GPS after finds the uh
the coordinate the position it
translates it to that and then the ECI
is the one that the satellite uses when
it tells you where it is and then you
need to go from ECI to ECF uh before you
use that positional information in the
satellite okay so let's talk about some
uh physics or orbital mechanics of of
the satellite so assume that your
satellite's position is given by a three
Vector P sub s which is x y z position
of the satellite in the ECI coordinate
system okay and first let's talk about
the ideal case so if Earth was a perfect
sphere with uniform mass density
um and there were no other perturbing
forces so it was only the the
gravitational force of this perfect
sphere acting on the satellite its
Dynamics would be basically governed by
uh uh the the Newton's law of motion
which is force equals mass times
acceleration right so the acceleration
of your satellite is the force divided
by by its mass and the only Force again
would be this gravitational uh force of
a perfect sphere so the acceleration of
the satellite which is the second
derivative of its position relative to
time would basically be given by this
simple equation here there's a constant
mu divided by the square of the distance
of the satellite to the Center of the
Earth so that's R sub s squared and this
P hat is a unit Vector that points from
the center of the earth to where the
satellite is and that determines the
direction of the acceleration of course
the Earth is pulling the ground is
pulling the the satellite towards the
Earth so it makes sense for the
acceleration to be in minus P hat
direction right it's it's always getting
uh accelerated towards the Earth right
uh mu in this equation is uh itself a
multiplication of two other constants
it's G times M where G is the universal
gravitational constant and M is the mass
of the Earth which is 5.9 times 10 to
the
24th there's a little typo here okay
and uh this is easy so if this was the
ideal case uh uh this you can actually
analytically solve and it turns out that
the the shape of the orbit becomes a
perfect ellipse with uh Earth at its
focal point okay now in reality as I
said this is not the case well for one
Earth is not a perfect sphere also its
mass density is not uniform as we know
and then there's a whole bunch of
secondary forces affecting on your
satellite so in reality the equation you
need to solve to find the trajectory of
of your satellite is this one given here
where the acceleration is given by this
equation here which has two terms one is
the gradient of VV is the gravitational
potential of the Earth right and then
there's this a sub D which is the kind
of like the lumped effect of all these
secondary forces acting on your
satellite and you can just sum them up
make them this additional perturbing
acceleration term that's that's getting
added here and uh just a reminder that
this uh the the gradient is basically
the vector of the first derivatives of
Phi with respect to the three
coordinates so it's partial D partial
act partial V partial X partial V
partial y partial B partial Z and you
evaluate that gradient at the position
the current position of your satellite
and that gives you basically what the
acceleration is this is called the two
body or the keplerian equation of motion
in principle you can solve this right
it's still a ordinary uh differential
equation so you can if you know V
you can find its gradient right and
let's say also a sub D is known or you
can ignore it if it's negligible and
then that gives you your acceleration
and if you integrate that once you get
velocity right because the acceleration
is the derivative of the velocity and
then you integrate again you get
position right so if you double
integrate this you can in principle get
the position of your satellite in
practice it is not done this way and the
reason is this V the gravitational
potential of the Earth the actual
basically model of it is extremely
complicated so it's this function given
here okay so don't worry we're not going
to do this I'm basically just just put
it in there to scare you off because
it's just very complicated I mean it's
not outrageous but it's this complicated
function it's modeled by what is called
a spherical harmonics it has an infinite
number of terms in it you can always
like approximate it with some finite sum
these PE uh LMS are called Legend
polynomials so those are some known
polynomials and then there's a whole
bunch of like constants that go in there
and a bunch of geometric parameters like
the Alpha and the and and the r and so
on and so forth okay so again this is
just it's in there just so you know it
is doable and the actual gravitational
field of the earth it's very well known
very well studied and in some
applications if need be you can actually
work with it okay but that's not how the
GPS does and the main reason is
computational complexity I mean this
function if you need to like constantly
uh well first find the the gradient of
it and then double integrate to find a
position it becomes uh very
computationally expensive
so the way uh it's done uh for for the
for the GPS is actually I'm pretty
elegant and and simple so what happens
is that every ephemeris message so the
core idea here is okay if you look at
very long time scales
the full trajectory of of this uh
satellite around the earth is this
complicated thing governed by the exact
gravitational potential of the earth and
other perturbing forces
but on much shorter time scales so if
you just consider a few minutes right or
seconds you can very well approximate it
by A Perfect ellipse right so in on a
much shorter time scale so again the
idea here is
say this is the Earth this is this
satellite orbiting
so in a perfect case it's it's a perfect
ellipsoid right in a non-perfect case
it's something else I don't know exactly
what it is but there's like some
deviations maybe or something maybe it's
something like that okay but if you look
at a very very short time scale like
just around here you can very well
approximate the actual black trajectory
by the blue uh ellipse right so and
that's how the GPS works as part of
every ephemeris message it sends just
six parameters six numbers basically
that are the approximation of the actual
trajectory of the satellite with an
ellipse right and that is what the
receiver uses to find the location of
the satellite and these are called the
orbital parameters there's also a
timestamp that is part of the ephemeris
message so it basically tells you at
this point in time t 0
my trajectory is very well approximated
by by an ellipse and these are the six
parameters you need to know to basically
uh know the shape and orientation of of
this ellipse okay so um
so those are the the basically the six
uh orbital parameters and as I said
there is a timestamp as part of the
ephemeris message uh and the that that
time is is also called the the epoch for
uh that message
and also uh remember that these
navigation messages are coming very
slowly right so you might receive one
every couple of minutes or maybe even
less
so it is not that's why the GPS
satellite doesn't just send you a
position it just doesn't send you an XYZ
right because the XYZ is only valid at a
single point in time and then you need
to to extrapolate between the two uh
navigation messages and if it's just one
XYZ there's no way for the receiver to
extrapolate so that's why instead the
the satellite tells you the trajectory
right it tells you the shape and
orientation of this ellipse so the
receiver can actually
extrapolate where the satellite is going
to be or interpolate between two
navigation messages and on top of that
just to make things more accurate not
only the satellite tells you the the
shape of this ellipse it also sends you
some secondary correction factors which
tells you over time how these orbital
parameters change and that helps the
receiver to even more accurate
interpolate between between two messages
so let's see what these six parameters
the first three
scribe the shape of the ellipse and also
where the satellite is on that
elliptical trajectory okay so pretty
simple uh it's in the lips there's very
many different parameterizations for it
the one that GPS uses is as part of the
ephemeris you get the a or the
semi-major axis of the ellipse you also
get the eccentricity okay so with that
you can perfectly basically find the
shape of this ellipse and also where the
Earth is that's the focal point right so
you just need to know a and the
eccentricity and that's it but you also
needs to tell
you am I on on this elliptical
trajectory and uh the the the velocity
of the satellite on this is not constant
okay again there's different
parametrizations that you can use to
basically uh find where uh the satellite
is the one that uh is used by the GPS
it's called the tower the time of
perigee so on this uh elliptical
trajectory there's a point P here which
is the closest point to the Earth on on
the trajectory so that's called the time
of period point of perigee and tau is
basically the time it's going to take
the satellite from this t0 which is the
transmit time to get to the point of
perigee right so it tells you okay
it's going to take me for instance I
don't know two hours to get to this
point p on the trajectory and with that
using that and some simple math the
receiver can back out where exactly the
satellite is
on the trajectory at time t 0 and also
extrapolate because it knows the
trajectory it knows where it is on it
right now and also it can basically uh
tell how it's going to move over time
only short periods of time right
remember because over long periods this
this trajectory is not going to be valid
this trajectory is only valid for
minutes right or seconds but still it's
it's pretty good uh for for for those
kinds of of calculations yes
oh excellent question so the question is
how does a satellite know the point of
perigee
um so
um this is where
um I think I I very briefly mentioned
that there's a very important part of
the GPS system which is the the ground
system there's these network of ground
stations that monitor the satellites and
constantly communicate with them so
that's actually it's told uh by by the
ground system the satellite A lot of
these orbital calculations are are done
on the ground and then they're
transmitted to the satellites uh so
that's that's basically how it's how
it's done yep
it kind of does so in terms of again the
question was does it does it take too
many resources for the GPS ground system
to kind of track all these satellites
and and you know tell them that all the
trajectory information
it kind of does it's not outrageous
again like by today's standards we're
talking about solving system a simple
differential equations and and things
like that so by today's standards not
really in the 70s yes it was considered
kind of like a heavy operation but again
I remember that there's only like 30
something satellites in orbit and
there's a lot of ground stations and uh
so if you kind of like distribute the
compute among them it's not that I mean
these days these kinds of of
calculations can run on a cell phone
basically so again in the 70s yes maybe
it was considered kind of like compute
heavy but today not really but ground
stations do a lot more than just this so
this is part of what they do but there's
a whole lot of like other stuff that
that the GPS ground system does okay so
so far these three parameters the a the
E that the
major axis the eccentricity and the time
of perigee describe the shape of this
elliptical trajectory and where the
satellite is on it okay but that's not
enough because remember we're in in a 3D
space so we also need to know the
orientation of this ellipse with respect
to the Earth right so if you will you
need three more parameters kind of like
at a pitch and a row and a yaw so three
angles to describe how this elliptical
plane is oriented right and that's the
other three uh basically orbital
parameters that uh the are part of the
ephemeris message again there's many
different formulations you can use to
describe the orientation of the ellipse
again for instance the a pitch role and
a yaw is a perfectly valid
parametrization but that's not what the
GPS uses it uses something slightly
different here's a picture that um
kind of describes it's three angles
they're called I uh big Omega and and
little Omega and what they are is Let Me
Maybe
add some color to the picture so here
you have two planes this one that I'm
highlighting in red is the equatorial
plane of the earth and the other one
let's keep it black that's the plane of
the elliptical trajectory of the of the
satellite so we want to kind of describe
the orientation between the two so the I
is the angle between the equatorial
plane and the orbital plane so that's
this angle so if you look at the two
surface normals of the two planes that's
the angle I okay and then big Omega it's
the longitude angle of the ascending
node and the ascending node is basically
if you look at this let me use a
different color here if you look at this
uh basically
elliptical trajectory let's say that's a
trajectory of the satellite at some
point it's going to cross the orbital
plane uh of uh I'm sorry the the
equatorial plane of of the earth and
that point is called the ascending note
the one where it goes from
uh underneath it to above it that's
called the ascending node and if you
calculate the longitude of that that is
your big Omega so that's the second
angle and the third one little Omega is
the angle between the ascending node and
the the the vector that points to the
point of perigee of the of the orbital
plane again this is a kind of the thing
you have to kind of look at it a little
bit and then it becomes clear exactly
what the three angles are again it's
just one parametrization to describe the
3D orientation of the orbital plane
okay so so those are the basically the
six parameters that are in in every
ephemeris message
um
and uh
these parameters again remember the the
six orbital parameters they're exact
only at time t 0 which is it the
transmit time of the navigation message
and
if if you deviate from t0 because of
these perturbing forces and other
effects your orbital parameters can
change okay and that's why uh as as part
of every ephemeris message there is also
correction factors that describe how
these uh six parameters are going to
change over time and then the receiver
can also apply the correction factors as
it's
interpolating uh the position of the
satellite between two navigation
messages okay so you get something exact
at time zero and then from this time
zero to the to the arrival of the next
Epoch uh or or navigation message you
use your correction factor and by you I
mean the receiver uses the correction
factors to constantly basically track
the position of the satellite in orbit
okay
um two questions
why not send ephemeris messages very
frequently why is it so slow send it
fast and then we don't need to apply
these correction factors and it's for a
very practical reason because it becomes
too computationally expensive for the
satellite if it needs to like constantly
uh communicate uh this and again uh when
it comes to satellites power consumption
is always a very very big constraint and
that was a design decision that was made
by the GPS design Engineers the other
question which we kind of already
answered is why not why doesn't the
receiver integrate the fully perturbed
equation of motion to find the satellite
orbit trajectory and again that's too
computationally
expensive for the receiver okay so for
these two reasons basically the design
decision was made to describe the the
trajectory with the six orbital
parameters plus the correction factors
and then send them on on kind of like a
slow over slow intervals
any questions
okay
um I I really hope you you you stop me
when things don't make sense because
uh it's really important I mean it's
it's it's my job to make sure when you
walk out of the door stuff we talked
about made sense so if it doesn't please
stop me and we can talk about and
clarify things and uh don't don't be shy
to really just flat out tell me hey this
this doesn't make sense and uh I'll try
to to clarify
so uh so far again we said there's
there's two things that the receiver
needs to estimate before it can start
localizing itself and one was the
position of the satellite or each
satellite in orbit and we we talked
about it so that's that that was the
first item that's checked now and now we
are going to talk about how these
ranging codes work and how
time-of-flight estimation is done using
them okay here I'm going to need
um it's going to become a little bit
Mass heavy and I really need your full
attention because this concept that we
are going to talk about now goes Way
Beyond GPS it's it's a very core idea
that we introduce it in GPS but we're
going to see it again and again in class
and generally for sensing this is one of
those really core uh very interesting
ideas so
let's uh kind of like focus on it
together and again at any point if it
things don't make sense stop me me right
away and let's talk about it
so let's first
simplified signal model for time of
flight estimation so we have a GPS
satellite that's transmitting a signal
and right now we're completely
abstracting out what the specifics of
the signal is we called it ranging codes
but it can be anything right now some X
of T is transmitted it's a waveform
right and then it gets some time Tau to
reach the receiver and the receiver
receives the Y of T which is X of T
minus Tau so it's some delayed version
of T and it also gets attenuated so for
completeness we've included this Alpha
parameter which is an attenuation Factor
okay very generic model and the job of
the receiver is to basically estimate
Tau what is the time of flight
now uh usually we any receiver to do DSP
or any type of like algorithms it works
with discrete signal so the signals are
sampled basically and let's say you have
some sampling frequency F sub s or a
sampling time T sub s so f is one over T
and then you work with the discretized
signal so you get X of K which is X of K
times your sampling interval K times TS
and then y of K is alpha x of K minus N
Sub Tau this N Sub tau is kind of like
the discretized time of flight uh so
it's going to be the floor of Tau over
your sampling interval TS okay so that's
kind of like super simplified uh already
signal model that we can work with and
let's frame an estimation problem uh
using this so you're the receiver you
have measured a y of K right and let's
say you also know what's a signal was
transmitted X of K is known to you so
you have previously agreed with the
transmitter that this is the exact
waveform X of K that you're going to
transmit and we're not going to change
that okay now you want to estimate the
attenuation and the time of flight and
subtau and Alpha
attenuation for GPS it doesn't really
matter there is nothing useful you can
do with it but as we see it's just a
byproduct of of this estimation problem
it just comes out of the equations and
some other applications it might be
interesting to know what the attenuation
was for GPS we only care about time of
flight how do we do this we can frame a
Lisa squares problem so basically now
you have this model right which is Alpha
times x of n minus N Sub Tau and you
want to fit the model to your
measurements which are y case right how
do we do that so one way is basically to
minimize the mean squared error between
your measurements and signal model right
so you sum over all K's you subtract y k
from the basically this fit which is
alpha x of K minus n you square all the
error terms sum them up that's your mean
squared error and then you want to pick
Alpha hat and n hat that minimize your
mean squared error right yes
on the last slides you said ciao was the
time of flight yes on this page you're
using in subject now yes like is there a
difference between the two yeah so the
question was uh on this slide we said
time of flight is Tau and then I kind of
like changed to to N Sub tile and are
these different or related they're
related so as we discretize the signal
or sample it with some sampling interval
T sub S as it's written over here it
basically N Sub tau is is the discrete
index that corresponds to the to the
time of flight right
um so so that's how it's it's like the
discrete equivalent of your your time of
flight basically
um okay
so so so this is basically our
optimization problem if we solve this
and minimize this objective function uh
the alpha and N that minimize this are
going to be our least squares estimates
of the time of flight and the
attenuation so let's solve this together
first thing is we expand this it's uh
just a square term so as you expand it
you get three terms right you get a sum
of Y squared you get Alpha squared times
sum of x squared or x minus N squared
and then you get the cross term which is
minus two alpha summation y k x k minus
n okay first term does not depend on N
or Alpha so this one you can just ignore
it the Y squared term right and what we
get then is this equation here and here
also have done a little thing I flipped
this sign inside and then changed Min to
the max just for mathematical
convenience there's really no
scientific reason behind it but just to
make the notation a little easier okay
so so this is what we want to minimize
right it's our objective function and
let's first estimate Alpha and the way
you do it when a function is given and
you want to maximize or minimize it you
take the derivative set it to zero so
let's take the derivative with respect
to Alpha set that to zero this is the
equation you get for your Alpha hat or
the least squares estimate to Alpha
and as you solve this so it's two times
this y k times summation y k times x k
minus n minus 2 Alpha hat times
summation of x squared so your Alpha hat
becomes basically this expression okay
so this is the least squares estimate of
the attenuation right now what we really
really care about is the n hat or n hat
Tau so to find that you can plug this
Alpha hat back into this equal equation
here and then solve for n hat right
plugging in it in things really simplify
very quickly as as you plug that in and
basically your n hat becomes uh the arc
Max of this function here
okay and if you look at this function
here something is interesting so it's a
ratio the numerator is the square of the
summation y k times x
k minus n and then the denominator is
summation over K of x squared K minus
the denominator here
is really the energy in your transmit
waveform X or a delayed version of it
right so K minus n minus n is just like
kind of just shifting or offsetting or
delaying your signal and then your
is squaring it and summing it up so
that's the total energy in your transmit
signal and it really does not depend on
N if you delay a signal the energy in it
does not change right so you can ignore
the denominator and just go find the max
of the numerator right
um so so and that's what you do and then
you're basically estimate of the time of
flight or n hat becomes the arc Max of
this function which we call ryx of N and
this is the cross correlation of your
received signal Y and the transmitted
waveform X which is basically this this
sum here right which is the same sum
that was on top here we have just
renamed it called it ryx and it's sum of
a k y k x k minus n this should look
familiar from say maybe a signal
processing course that you've taken it's
awfully close to the the correlation
between X and Y not exactly the
correlation though there's like a minus
sign change somewhere I'll let you
figure out like the exact difference but
basically it's kind of like the
correlation of X with X of n with Y of
minus n or some something like that like
you flip one and then do the the
correlation the point is it's it's kind
of like a linear filter right
um You have your y you have different x
with different delays right and then you
kind of uh multiply and and sum over K
and then what you want to do is you want
to square to the sky
and find the value of n that maximizes
it right so if you calculate your Ry X
and then Square it then you have this
function of n and then you can just look
at this function and find where there is
a peak and the index for that Peak
basically gives you your time of flight
delay right there's one more
simplification we can do and that's the
fact that we know Y is just a scaled and
delayed version of X right from the
physics of our problem we know Y is just
Alpha times x of n minus sum and and Tau
so using this information
and if you plug that y for that model
for Y into this this cross correlation
basically just becomes the
autocorrelation of X with itself right
so what I'm doing here just just to be
very concrete I'm setting this equal to
sum over k for why I'm plugging in alpha
x of
K minus N Sub Tau and then that's
multiplied by X of K minus n right Alpha
as a constant comes out and then what's
under the summation is just the
autocorrelation of X that is shifted by
N Sub Tau
right
so just to summarize now now we
basically have a procedure or an
algorithm to find a time of flight right
so here's kind of like a high level
summary of it a signal Y is received
right and then you correlate that and by
correlate I mean
that equation that we just looked at
that the summation of of Y and and X of
K minus n so you correlate that with X
of n which is the waveform that the
transmitter and the receiver agreed on
we know that was the the transmit so you
do that correlation you get this
correlation function out it's a function
of n right and you can take you can
square it or just take the absolute
value of it and then
find the maximum value or find the peak
in this correlation and the N or the
index that is the peak that is your n
hat which is basically the discrete the
discretized time of flight and then what
is uh if you want to change that or
convert that from an index to an actual
time we said that Tau hat is n hat Tau
times your TS which is your your
sampling interval basically right uh so
that's that's the procedure this is also
in in communication Theory this is a
very well known technique for receiving
signal packets it's called matched
filtering right so in communication
systems this is used very often
now here's what is very interesting so
as we did this derivation uh we did not
make any assumption about what x is
right so we completely abstracted out
the specifics of x t or X of n the
discrete version of it
but so so in general it can be anything
right the receiver and the transmitter
can agree on any waveform they like and
use that for for this time of flight
measurement but from this procedure now
that we have an algorithm that helps us
decide what is a good choice for X what
are what properties should X have to
make this procedure better more robust
and easier to do okay and um so so at a
very high level there's this function
that comes out of the correlated we call
it like uh r y x of n
right which is as we said just a scaled
and offsolute version of the
autocorrelation of X so it's Alpha times
rxx
of n minus N Sub Tau
so if you were free and then what the
way you find N Sub tau is that you look
at the let me use a different marker
here
you look at the
um absolute value or the square of this
Let's ignore Alpha right it's just a
constant we don't care about it we care
about finding this this enter so as a
function of n
if I plot say the absolute value or the
absolute value squared let's just plot
the absolute value for now apps of rxx
of n minus
N Sub Tau
right
um
it's going to be some function and
hopefully it has some Peak and where
this peak is is my n hat of Tau okay
this is kind of the ideal so so the
ideal function you want here is
something that has a very sharp Peak
where your actual uh n hat is and is
almost zero everywhere else
and mathematically that's called a Delta
function right so if you can find an X
with an autocorrelation that is very
close to a Delta function so it has a
very sharp large Peak and what we call
the side lobes which is the stuff here
and here is very low ideally zero that
would be very easy for this procedure if
if you have some other X where uh has
like very large side lobes and a peak
here these side lobes can be Troublesome
right so because we are free to choose
any X
we should find one with what we call
very good autocorrelation properties and
good autocorrelation properties again is
sharp Peak and very low side lobes as
close to a Delta function as possible
and then that makes our lives really
really easy when it comes to Tama flight
estimation now it turns out that these
ranging codes that for instance GPS uses
are exactly chosen according to this
criteria these are these basically
functions that have really really good
autocorrelation properties right and
generally there is a family of waveforms
that are called pseudorandom noise or
PRN sequences and these all have very
good autocorrelation properties and
from this family of PRN sequences the
specific ones that GPS for instance uses
they are called maximal length sequences
or MLS or also M sequences and those are
kind of like a subcategory of of prns
that the GPS uses again exactly for for
this reason that they have very good as
we see we will see in a minute
autocorrelation properties but also they
have some other good properties they're
very very easy to generate almost free
to generate using just a very simple
linear feedback shift register as I'll
show you you can generate these codes
and if you have a shift register with n
Bits that generates a code of a length 2
to the N minus 1. that's just from the
mathematics of it and here now you can
sort of connect two dots when we're
talking about these ranging codes like
the ca or the py everything all the
number of chips and so on was a multiple
of 10 10 23 right and that's where the
number is coming from because these use
M sequences
that are have have 10 bits and 2 to the
10 minus 1 is 10 23 and and that's the
length of or the number of chips in
these codes
um there's there's beautiful beautiful
mathematical theory behind these codes
and there's just like uh so many very
interesting things about them you're
gonna barely scratch the surface
um I I know people have done their
entire phds on on these codes uh we're
not going to go that deep of course but
I I want to tell you a little more about
them uh let's first start with
what is a linear feedback shift register
and how do we generate these codes
here's a very simple example so we're
going to generate a 15 chip code so
that's 2 to the four minus 1 which based
on what I said you need a length for
linear feedback shift register okay so
this is how it operates so the shift
register here is just have basically uh
four uh memory bits so it only takes
four bits of memory right and you
initialize it with four bits you start
with one one one one one right that's
the initial State and then you take
feedback from uh say two of these uh
memory bits and modular 2 add them and
feed it back to the input right so at
each clock cycle what happens is that
every bit is shifted to the right so
you go right right right and then you
push out one bit and that's your code
waveform X of T coming out and then uh
the input is is coming from this
feedback so after the first clock cycle
you generate the first chip of your code
which is this one coming out and then
what you push into the A3 is modulo 2
added of A1 and a0 they're both one so
you push in a zero
and then you just continue right and
what comes out of it is again of course
the first four bits are going to be all
ones because that's how we initialized
the shift register and then after that
it's gonna basically based on the
feedback like go to zeros and ones so it
generates this thing for you which is
one one one one zero zero zero one zero
zero and so on but the point is it
repeats with a period of exactly 15. so
if you look at the first 15 bits and we
call that a code word here
then it starts to review so infinitely
repeats the exact same code of length 15
for you over and over again so this is
just to illustrate
that it's very very easy to generate
these codes right almost almost free
um I mean in
but today's computer standards this is
literally free okay
what's also important is that this this
we've taken the feedback from A1 and a0
uh this is not random right so you need
to take your feedback from various
specific bits in the shift register to
get an M sequence out with the good
properties that we want and there's ways
of like finding for a given length what
are the the feedback tabs that you need
and there's tables that that tell you
that so for instance in the in the
previous slide if you go to this this
hyperlink here uh
it's it's a very interesting website
that tells you I want to generate a
1023-bit m sequence and it tells you
what a specific feedback tabs you need
to use for your shift register and then
you can generate that another thing to
note which is also practically extremely
important for GPS is that say here for
instance we're generating uh 15 15 chip
M sequence it's not unique so you can
have different 15 chip M sequences with
different basically
shift register feedback tabs and the
autocorrelation of of those different 15
chip M sequences are all at exactly good
at this or identical to each other
they're all very good but the cross
correlations are very low and that's
where these codes are like almost
orthogonal if we think of this cross
correlation as kind of like an inner
product between the two the cost
correlations of different M sequences
what different number with the same
number of chips is is very low close to
in the in the limit that the codes
become very long it actually approaches
zero which I'll tell you it's an
important property so just as a summary
uh why GPS uses M sequences they have
lots and lots of interesting properties
but specific to GPS they're very easily
generated you can generate them in
Hardware or in software almost for free
as I'll show you in a minute they have
very good autocorrelation properties
with very low side lobes as we want for
to do a time of flight estimation and
different M sequences or mls's of the
same length have very small cross
correlation so they're almost orthogonal
and that's how the receiver can
distinguish the signals between
different GPS satellites because each
satellite transmits a unique M sequence
for you so let's look at the
autocorrelation of these M sequences uh
remember that we use bpsk modulation for
these signals so we map the zero and one
bits to plus one and -1 right that's how
they're transmitted and let
T chip be the duration of one one chip
of your code and then we're gonna have
we're gonna sample it right so we work
with discrete signals and let's say you
get M samples per chip so visually
basically what we have is let's say this
is your code waveform
and this here is going to be your T chip
right and say if for instance m equals
three so if you sample that three
samples per chip you get like one two
three samples
for this chip and all of these are going
to be for instance plus one
okay that's how the sampling works so X
of n again is X of n times TS which in
terms of the T chip and the m is X of n
t chip over M and then the N varies from
0 to M times n minus one big n is the
total number of chips m is the number of
samples per chip so uh your index varies
from zero to M times n minus one now
um to simplify our notation let's call M
times n k so K is the total number of
samples in the discrete code basically
after sampling at M samples per chip and
then we can find the autocorrelation
function here because these uh signals
are periodic right so it has 2 to the N
minus 1 chips and it just repeats as the
shift register operates we don't need to
like find an infinite sum for the
correlation we just sum over one period
and it's called the cyclical correlation
for the for that reason so we just take
one period of your X if n uh very K from
0 to B K minus 1 and then we're finding
the autocorrelation of X so you multiply
X of K by X of K minus n but for this K
minus n just so that it doesn't go out
of bands of of one period we do that
module okay
right so as you go outside the one
period you just wrap around your your
index so so we are always bound to just
one period of the signal and that is
basically your autocorrelation function
now uh as you do the math and find this
function it becomes uh this discrete
triangle function which is very
interesting so for n equals zero you get
a value of one so if you plug n equals
zero into this equation the value of the
autocorrelation is exactly equal to one
and then as you deviate n your index
from one go to positive or negative side
as you see it linearly decreases so
that's where this triangle uh happens
and then if your n is
basically bigger than M minus one you
get this constant side lobe level which
is negative one over n and n remember is
the total number of chips in your M
sequence so as you increase then your
side lobe levels become smaller and
smaller and in the limit of like very
large codes they actually approach zero
so you almost get like a perfect
triangle with zero side lobes as the as
the correlation function
okay so um
one important thing about this function
again because we are working with
periodic signals the autocorrelation
function also is periodic with a period
of K where K is the total number of
samples in one period of your uh code or
sample code so rxx of n plus a multiple
of K is exactly equal to rxx of K
and the for the cyclic correlation uh
again it's it's like a linear operation
so if you shift your X for instance by
some n0
the autocorrelation of also gets shifted
uh by by the same and zero that's just a
property of of this linear filter
basically
um
okay so this is basically here where I'm
reiterating the same fact that the minus
1 over n is kind of like your side lobe
level for these codes and as you
increase n which is the number of chips
you get smaller and a smaller side Loops
so just to compare your course
acquisition code for instance remember
uh it had 10 23 chips so your side lobe
level is -1 over ten twenty three
already pretty low but if you just
compare that to py which is the military
code and that had 6 times 10 to the 12
chips it has much much Lower Side lobe
and that's why the military GPS gets
better SNR because it's less the
correlation functions are kind of less
noisy right now graphically this is
perhaps this is the easiest way to see
what's happening here so our the 15 chip
code that we generated using the shift
register and a couple slides before
let's sample that at four samples per
chip and then we find the
autocorrelation function of it and
that's this is rxx of n as a function of
N and it's exactly the properties that
we want right you get very sharp Peak at
zero and that's your triangle function
right there you see the samples linearly
drop as you go away from zero and then
you get this side lobe level which in
this case is exactly minus one over uh n
which is 15.
okay
so so so that's that's that now just to
show you why these codes are magical I
mean we call them pseudorandom noise so
kind of the name is misleading because
it suggests that they're just like
random bits right so let's generate a 15
chip random binary sequence you go on
python you use your Rand function
binarize it to zeros and one 15 bits and
then sample that up for samples per chip
and then find the autocorrelation
function of that and you get something
like this okay well yes you still have
the peak is at zero sure but look at the
side lobe levels here and compare that
to the m sequence I mean it's day and
night different right I mean assume like
how much SNR gain you get again remember
to find time of flight you're searching
for this peak right so if your side
lobes are too high there's going to be
noise and non-idealities and
non-linearities added that you know
corrupt the signal so if you don't have
a very solid foundation for your
autocorrelation to start with as you add
noise and other non-idealities it's just
going to make it very very hard for you
to find that Peak so that's why you
don't want to work with random sequences
you want to work with these codes that
are have really really good correlation
properties to to start with Okay
um
one more thing so let's look at one more
example here we're working with slightly
longer coats so 31 chips so these are
coming from a five bit is that far yeah
five bit shift register and now we're
generating two of them okay so we we do
two different shift registers with
feedback tabs let's say we go to that
website that I should uh there's a link
you go where it says okay five five bit
shift lfsrs and you choose two of the uh
basically feedback tab values that it
gives you
you generate those uh shift registers
and then you get an X1 and an X2 both
are 31 chips and we sample them at three
samples per chip okay if you find the
autocorrelation of X1 so RX1 X1 or rx2
X2 they're identical exact same both
give you this very nice triangle right
sharp Peak with side lobe level that is
-1 over uh 31 right now if you look at
the cross correlation of the two so you
find rx1x2 you would see that it's not
exactly zero everywhere but it's pretty
low it doesn't have like a sharp Peak or
anything like that so that this is that
principle of orthogonality of these
codes so now from this you can kind of
imagine if you are a receiver
and there's this like 30-something
satellites in orbit each is transmitting
a different M sequence and you know
exactly all the M sequences but then you
can build correlators and make the
kernel of these correlators correspond
to different codes from different
satellites and as you feed in you
receive signals by this principle of
orthogonality each correlator just shows
a peak for the code that corresponds to
the kernel of the correlation and it
naturally filters out the interference
from the other satellites for you and
this is what is uh the the principle of
basically code division multiple access
that the receiver the GPS system
receivers use and that's how they can
distinguish signals from different
satellites although they're transmitted
at the exact same frequency so you get a
lot of in principle interference when
you receive these signals but by by
basically just using this almost
orthogonality of the signals through the
correlators you can completely separate
them out okay
so let's summarize how does this time of
flight ranging work
for for the receiver so we start with
the GPS satellite and let's look at the
idealized scenario right now so we are
not accounting for timing offsets and a
few other effects that I'll tell you so
let's say this is our ideal scenario so
the satellite transmits a unique code X
of T at some carrier frequency F Sub C
which is one of the five GPS frequencies
X of T and the carrier frequency are
known to the receiver right and what the
receiver does is as it receives a signal
it's it's coming in modulated at F Sub C
right so it first demodulates the signal
by the carrier frequency to bring it
basically to baseband and what it gives
you is just some delayed version of xft
by time of flight so receiver recovers
this y of T which is X of T minus Tau
and we are ignoring attenuation right
remember that there is some some
attenuation Factor Alpha here
it does not affect
the GPS in in in in any way so you can
completely ignore that assume there is
no attenuation we're just looking for a
time of flight
again this is idealized scenario so
receiver has its clock perfectly
synchronized with the transmitter for
now so Tau sub D is zero we'll talk
about that later and what the receiver
can do is that it generates a local
replica of the ranging code call that x
x hat of T right so X hat of T is
exactly equal to X of T because X of T
is known to the receiver the clock has
perfectly synchronized so you can
generate a local replica of the ranging
code and then what the receiver does is
that it calculates the correlation
between X hat which is the local replica
and Y of T which is the delayed version
of the code and that correlation will
have a peak exactly at the time of
flight time right or the in the discrete
version it has a Peak at the index that
corresponds to the discretized time of
flight so the you find the peak you find
the index of the of the correlation for
for that Peak and then you estimate your
your time of flight how hot is it
receiver's estimate of the time of
flight is just n hat times the sampling
interval which is which is T sub s and
then you can convert the time to the
range using the time-of-flight principle
so you just multiply your Tau Hat by the
speed of light and that gives you the
range okay
simple procedure let's see how it works
kind of graphically so again same same
idea I'm just uh this is some pictures
to to illustrate so your satellite is
transmitting this code uh ranging code X
of T it's some M sequence and this star
here is just for us to be visually you
know track at reference point in time
there's no uh
physical significance to it really so
that's X of T what the receiver receives
is X of T delayed by some Tau right so
your star shifts by
Tau seconds right but also because the
receiver is perfectly synchronized to
the transmitter it can generate a local
replica X hat of the code which is
perfectly aligned with the satellites
version okay for now we are ignoring
timing offsets and then what you do is
you you look at the correlation of X hat
with Y right and that correlation right
now there's no noise everything is ideal
everything is perfect so it gives you a
perfect triangle function with a Peak at
n hat which is your discrete time of
what it's just Tau over TS a little
floor of Tau over TS you find your n hat
multiplied by Ts that gives it Tau hat
multiplied by C that gives you range so
that's how ranging an idealized scenario
works okay now let's talk about a few
non-idealities the first one is of
course which is the big one is the fact
that you never have your clock as a
receiver perfectly synchronized with GPS
right so what happens in that scenario
is that the local replica of the code
that the the receiver generates is it is
not perfectly aligned it is offset by
some Tau sub D from the receiver it's
okay you can still do everything we
talked about you can look at the
correlation of your local replica with x
find the correlation Peak and convert
that to a time of flight but now you
should remember that what you recover is
not just the time of flight Tau what you
recover is Tau plus your timing offset
Tau sub d right so then when you convert
that to range when you multiply by by
the speed of light you don't get the
physical range you get what we call the
pseudo range call it rho so rho is c
times Tau hat and Tau hat in this case
is the actual Tau the physical time of
what plus the totality
c times tau is the physical range R and
then you get this error term which is c
times Tau D that the receiver later
needs to correct for right but for now
from these principles using these codes
you the receiver recovers as pseudo
range for every satellite not the
physical range and next time I'll tell
you how you can convert your pseudo
range to a physical range there's two
more non-idealities just to make things
more complicated for the receiver that I
want to talk about the first one is
Doppler shift
so what Doppler shift is is that in in
practice the neither the receiver in
most cases and definitely not the
transmitter are stationary right these
are moving and especially the satellite
is moving at very high velocities so
they have some relative velocity Delta V
which is the velocity of the receiver
minus the velocity of the satellite now
what happens in in practice is that if
there is a component of the Velocity
that is radial and by radial I mean it's
in the direction of the line that
connects the receiver to the transmitter
if that Delta V has a radial component
that would cause from the receiver's
point of view a shift in the carrier
frequency which is called the Doppler
shift and the Doppler shift is given by
this expression here so you take your
Delta V you project it into the radial
direction to this this R hat is a unit
Vector that points from the receiver to
the satellite and Delta V inner product
with r hat you kind of project that
relative velocity to find the component
of it that is radial divide that by the
speed of light multiplied by your
carrier frequency and that is the
Doppler shift F sub d
so receiver even if everything was
perfect it had like a perfect uh Crystal
oscillator and there was no noise or
anything just because of the movement uh
from the receiver's point of view the
signal doesn't come at a carrier
frequency of f c it comes at FC shifted
by the Doppler shift okay in reality
there's other things there's like
inaccuracies in the local oscillators
that the receiver uses add some timing
Jitter
so that also uh kind of becomes uh kind
of like an apparent Doppler shift and
this effect can be pretty big so for
like typical velocities with GPS
satellites and and and and devices that
operate on Earth F sub D can be as as
large as plus and minus 10 kilohertz
which is significant now what happens is
that as I was describing this procedure
of of time of flight ranging the first
step for the receiver was to demodulate
the receive signal by F Sub C to bring
it to baseband right now if you ignore
your Doppler shift if you just use the
nominal carrier frequency you don't
bring your signal to baseband there's
going to be some offset modulation by
the Doppler shift right and that would
significantly almost entirely kill your
SNR correlation SNR
um so it is essential for the receiver
to also estimate the Doppler shift
somehow and track it and when it wants
to demodulate not just demodulate by the
nominal carrier frequency FC it should
it should modulate by FC plus the
Doppler shift to perfectly bring your
receive signal down to baseband and then
do correlation on it right super
essential so uh just to summarize uh
there's there's there's a receiver to
find pseudo ranges it needs to do two
things it needs to find and and track
and compensate for a Doppler shift and
it also needs to find the these
time-of-flight plus its timing offset
Tau plus top D using the correlation
principle and then it can recover a
pseudo range to each satellite and then
it can use the pseudo ranges to
basically find a time of flight
I'm sorry it can use the pseudo ranges
to to localize itself and that would be
the next topic we talk about there's a
third complication here and I'll briefly
mention it and complete it next time
because you're running out of time and
that has to do with the fact that when I
introduced this concept of correlation I
told you that it is because we're
transmitting signals periodically your
correlation function is also periodic
right we just calculated over one period
of the code but it is a periodic
function right so your rxx if you add
any multiple of the code length to the
index the value doesn't change so
graphically what happens is is if I uh
do this ryx hat which is the correlation
of my received signal with the local
replica of the code if I calculate that
and plot that not over just one period
just K samples but over like all
possible values of n it's a periodic
function which means the peak also
repeats every K samples right so you
don't get just one Peak if you look at
an extended
base for this this function you actually
get an infinite number of Peaks it
repeats every K samples which is the
duration of your code so then the
question is this idea of range ambiguity
is like which of these infinite number
of Peaks is the real peak which of them
corresponds to the actual time of flight
and then which are just artifacts of the
math right it's very important because
if you just pick the first one you don't
know is that is that real or is it just
an artifact of the math and next time
I'll tell you how you disambiguate
there's a few different ideas for range
this ambiguation any questions before we
quit
yes like geostationary orbits is the
Doppler effect reduced or is it still
present
because as well first first receiver can
move you're in a car you're moving so so
so that's still affects it there is some
very lucky situations that kind of like
the the two movements cancel each other
or there is no radial component to it or
something like that but almost always
there is some Doppler shift yeah
okay I'll see you next time thank you